alright so I wanted to do a little bit
more on the torture report which came
out yesterday of course actually just an
hour to after the report came out jimmy
dore and i did a video on our initial
thoughts on it which you can find right
here there's an annotation right around
there somewhere but what I wanted to
talk about here so of course of course
of course we knew about you know
waterboarding and sleep deprivation
stuff like that apparently there were
some new things that we hadn't heard
about like making the guys stand on
broken limbs now the new phrase that is
in our lexicon unfortunately is rectal
rehydration you can google it if you
want to find out what that is and among
amongst a bunch of other stuff that
happened that has been going on for
years basically in secret it's very
unclear who exactly knew about what how
high up the chain things went did things
start at the top and go down this I mean
it's really just very confusing which is
sort of how the government and the CIA
kind of has to operate so everyone knows
what's going on and nobody knows what's
going on all at the same time so I
didn't want to get too bogged down in
the specifics of it but I do want to say
that you know there's no evidence as far
as I know and please correct me if I'm
wrong there is no evidence that torture
actually works they give you information
but often information that is incorrect
or just because they don't want to be in
pain anymore or have water on them
anymore rectally rehi whatever it is but
there is no real concrete evidence that
this stuff actually works that's number
one but I really want to talk about in
this video is what do we do now okay we
know this was going on look this was
ordered by you know look I guess
President Bush it sounds certainly we
know a dick cheney was involved Donald
Rumsfeld was involved right and then it
got the okay from Congress so that's
part of the funny part here is that you
know the congressional Democrats
released this a lot of them like Dianne
Feinstein they're also the ones that
authorized it now is again it's a little
unclear how much they knew but you know
they authorized things and then if
goes down that they don't know about
there's still a little bit at fault sort
of like when they authorize the NSA to
spy on everybody and then they didn't
get upset about it until they found out
that the NSA was spying on them so
everybody's sort of at fault here but
what do you do now is the question I
don't know do we charge everybody you
can't just charge the guys on the bottom
who were doing the torture because they
were told by the guys up top to do it
which is sort of the Nuremberg defense
these in World War two or do you go all
the way up I
know exactly what you I'm curious to
know to hear what you guys think because
we have to do something now that this
information is out